martin biron christian dufour à la
question gay bonsoir
c'est pas terminer cette histoire au
parti libéral du québec je fais entendre
madame anglade qui on a ajouté une
couche sur madame à propos de madame en
tuant dix ans d'abord de l'île voir la
fin de l'extrait c'est terminé il n'a
plus d'avenir au parti libéral du québec
elle ne sera pas ne pourrait pas
reposé sa candidature elle explique
pourquoi et je fantôme je suis à requins
après que voulu calmer le jeu vieux
routier du caucus libéral bon reviens
moi comme chef je ne prendrai pas de
décision basée sur un lien que j'ai avec
une personne ou un autre je vais prendre
des décisions basées sur les faits qu'on
me donne basée sur les faits qui
arrivent et quand je vois des faits
quand je vois des faits qui me disent
qu'il ya des gens qui ne sont pas
traités de la manière dont ils devaient
être traités quand je vois des
situations où les gens n'ont pas reçu le
respect qu'ils devraient avoir
je n'ai pas le choix que d'agir et de
dire que c'est tolérance zéro
avec la quantité d'informations que j'ai
aujourd'hui avec les faits qui l'ont été
qui m'ont été présentés je ne vois pas
de quelle manière cela se produirait
dès jeudi lors du caucus qui avait lieu
par paul feig que le parti libéral
allait rebondir en 2022 et j'ai
pleinement confiance à mende à anglet
les périodes difficiles bien sûr ce
qu'on vit actuellement mais moi je sais
une chose il faut travailler pour la
prochaine élection et il faut travailler
en équipe tout le monde en équipe et
c'est ce que je vais m'appliquer à faire
comme président du caucus et aston
martin avec la quantité d'informations
que j'ai aujourd'hui et avec les faits
qui m'ont été présentés je ne vois pas
de quelle manière ça elle pourrait
revenir donc on parce que là encore une
fois le processus a pas été jusqu'au
bout on ne sait pas il n'y a pas eu de
rapport indépendant de l'assemblée
nationale mais à sa face même la chef
décide que c'est trop grave c'est ce
qu'on comprend oui donc la carrière de
marie mon petit et les terminer au parti
libéral du québec en tout cas du moins
tenter tout si longtemps que dominique
anglade sera chef de ce parti là il y en
a beaucoup des témoignages moi j'en ai
eu et j'ai des collègues qui en ont
collecté plusieurs ils sont assez
faciles à récupérer alors probablement
que madame anglade a eu 20 des coûts de
ces témoignages la selo quand même
aujourd'hui gagner je dirais la première
manche de la bataille parce que quand
même c'est pas n'importe qui marie
maupetit c'est une proche de dominique
anglade c'est la première à l'avoir
appui à sa course à la direction elle a
joué un rôle majeur dans son élection à
la tête du parti libéral elle vit à
renvoyer l'ascenseur en lui donnant le
prestigieux portefeuille de la santé
c'est une femme de confiance alors elle
mène croix sur cet allié là pour envoyer
un message clair à ses troupes que le
harcèlement l'intimidation
elle n'en veut pas alors il lui reste
d'autres étapes a gagné d'abord la
deuxième étape je pense que c'est le
caucus de demain demain
le mercredi c'est le caucus statutaire
l'on pourra peut-être en revenir mais il
va avoir des enjeux étaient donc le cas
de non bar est donc à l'unc et christian
elle n'a pas est ce qu'à vos yeux elle
n'a pas donc besoin d'attendre les
conclusions d'une enquête indépendante
pour tirer la langue sur l'avenir de
madame montpetit alec vous savez les
chiffres sont souriants ils peuvent
décider qui se présente qui ne se
présente pas quitte à accepter au caucus
qui ne l'est pas ça veut dire que les
informations que dominique anglade
possède sont assez sérieuse pour que
même si une enquête
se déroulent elles ne veulent plus que
ce soit elle qui représente donc pas là
mon petit le parti libéral dans maurice
richard sûr c'est la prérogative du chef
il peut décider si oui ou non on veut et
cette personne se présente aux
prochaines élections elle a décidé que
non donc ça semble assez sérieux pour
que 10 s'est terminée avec nous on dit
avec le parti libéral mais en réalité ça
veut convaincre le mans dire que la
carrière politique de marie-paule petit
terminé le joueur pour un autre parti
politique la récupère ici elle est à ce
point m'a chassé du parti libéral donc
pour s avouer que c'est la fin j'imagine
s'expliquer à un moment donné donné sa
version des faits mais le parti libéral
a clairement décidé là que peu importe
qu'elle arrivait c'était trop important
pour qu'elle porte les couleurs du parti
mais mon prochaines élections q siens
c'est le privilège de 20 ans enlevée
hâte de prendre ces décisions là c'est
pas un droit en fait que de ceux de
faire partie de nos partis se ressaisir
on peut se demander est ce que le fait
qu'elle avait l'air près de madame
montpetit dans le passé est-ce que pas
en fait la tentation guen humaine
d'embêter un peu plus ce qu'on a mais
très autrement mais suis je le seul à
être un peu mal à l'aise devant quelque
chose qui est tendance à se répéter de
plus en plus en fait non il ya des
choses qui sortent on nous dira beaucoup
de témoignages non sa samba kâ blanc
mais on sait pas qui accuse bon c'est
pas de quoi la personne est accusée
précisément c'est de plus en plus comme
simple et jenson ont détruit je
m'entraîne défendre dans la monture
aucune idée en fait de ce qu'elle fait
les poches du sel est ce qu on appelle
des principes de justice naturelle qu'on
apprend à la faculté de droit quand j'ai
fait mon cours de droit en première
année 1 que quand quelqu'un est accusé
de quelque chose il faut qu'on sache de
prêt est accusée au juste qui font ça
qu'on sache
qui l'accusent je constate que dans
notre société les nouvelles instances
qui sont liés à des comportements
déplacés des concepts vagues en fait ne
respecte pas sûr possible de schiste
actuelle et moi ça me dérange au delà de
la tunique politique que je comprends
très bien le jeu qu'on peut je peux
corriger vous comme citoyen mais ça me
dérange parce que c' est parfaite le
joli raid est et saint martin
madame anglade doit avoir j'imagine
l'appui du caucus pour faire ce qu'elle
fait là donc est ce que selon voilà elle
l'inscrit son autorité la belle la
déclaration de pierre arcand aujourd'hui
était quand même importante parce que
c'est un ancien chef par intérim et
s'éteint un 2d de la vieille garde parce
qu'une de ses difficultés à l'intérieur
de son caucus et de faire le pont entre
les jeunes la génération montante et la
génération sortante qui a servi
notamment sous jean charest ou souffler
couillard et qui sont toujours loyaux à
ces deux anciens premiers ministres et
madame anglade elle veut faire une croix
sur cette période là et c'est plus
difficile finalement pour ses plus vieux
députés là de lui être loyal à elle à
dominique anglade alors on comprend que
madame ont-ils donc on n'avait pas
beaucoup d'alliés il avait beaucoup de
l'adversaire dans le caucus ouais pas
mal bon
ok
mais mon père aussi
qu'est ce que monsieur barrette décidera
de faire
plaisir je trouve que c'est un énorme
test de leadership pour madame à anglade
elle est élue par acclamation chef du
parti libéral jusqu'à présent le fait
des efforts entre autres pour se
rapprocher de la majorité francophone
mais c'est comme ça le parti libéral
d'aujourd'hui ne semble pas porteur de
quelque chose qu'on peut identifier
donc pour elle sait maintenant qu'elle
doit prouver qu'elle le coffre pour
mener l'opposition officielle au combat
de la prochaine élection très bien je
vous parlais absolument de l' annonce
d'aujourd'hui mais non pas des
allégements parce que bon on reviendra
sur noël pas encore fixé le 15 novembre
karaoké très bien dans ok le ciné
stations de ski sont un peu plus libre
mais je veux revenir sur et je vais vous
faire entendre monsieur dubé maintenant
sur la fameuse échéance du 15 novembre
c'est comme le si on avait perdu la
mémoire que bodart le fond rien n'a pas
vraiment eu des géants on est comme
tout le monde le voit comme moitié chez
fonds pour bouger et les gens qui sont
qui sont pas vaccinés on en avait un
petit peu moins que 14000 qui n'avait
pas réussi a reçu au moins une première
dose bien aujourd'hui à un petit peu
presque trois semaines plus tard on est
à 12 mail dont moi je dis que
l'aiguillât pour suffisamment bouger ce
que je vous dirais le jeu va continuer
des discussions qu'on a avec la santé
publique puis tous les intervenants
c'est rare alec je veux pas faire du
puisqu'un agit de la douleur je me suis
résumé
ben célébra presque y avait presque
envie de dire celle là ça peut marcher
cette menace n'a pas marché
l'aiguilleur pas bougé on va être
obligés de travailler avec eux n'a pas
le choix de
payer pour cela je recevais françois
legault à mon émission la semaine
dernière
certains secteurs pour cinq ans les
travailleurs de la santé oms va être
capable d'imposer
pendant la marche et la semaine dernière
avoir l'attitude de christian dubé
effectivement je pense pas qu'il ya
encore beaucoup d'espoir d'être capable
de convaincre ceux qui veulent pas aller
se faire vacciner d'y aller vous savez
aujourd'hui en colombie-britannique ont
émis la menace à exécution et 3300
travailleurs de la santé qui vont être
suspendus un seul incident en trois mois
ils n'ont pas été chercher leurs doses
de vaccins ils vont tout simplement être
con j'ai dit ça peut avoir l'air
beaucoup 3300 mètres pauvres se ramène
ça ici c'est comme si on avait six ou
5000 travailleurs de la santé qui
n'étaient pas vaccinés qu'on les mettait
à piedmont est encore à 12 13 buts quand
même énorme pour un système de santé
aussi fragile et on a effectivement
l'impression qu'on sera capable d'y
arriver que les tests dans le fond les
tests routinier de trois fois par
semaine qui sont imposés qu'ils sont là
pour rester mince entre une seul rempart
contre les éclosions dans le milieu de
la santé parce qu'on sera pas capable de
convaincre suffisamment de gens d'aller
se faire vacciner pour imposer sur le
premier et des jeux de mots presley et
si vous ne voulez pas aller vous faire
vacciner c'est pas les propos
d'aujourd'hui ou de monsieur legault la
semaine dernière chez vous entre autres
qui vont faire que j'allais y aller
parce que vous sentez bien vous allez
pour faire envoyer crise oui c'est clair
que le discours du gouvernement a changé
c'est une très très bonne chose parce
que l'on est dans la réalité on n'est
pas dans le dogmatisme on n'est pas dans
l'idéologie center du risque zéro
rappelons que les québécois sont
massivement vacciner deux fois on est
presque à 90% rappelons des choses qu'on
ne dit pas assez là que c'est mieux de
se faire soigner par une infirmière
vacciner que peut être soignée pas tout
qu'une infirmière pro vaccinaux pas
nécessairement à la couvrir les gens qui
sont pas vaccinés on veut leur imposer
deux tests par semaine donc c'est clair
qu'un risque on sait jamais ce que ça
peut donner mais le gouvernement jugé et
je pense qu'il fait bien que le risque
serait plus grand fait que se départir
de ces travailleurs là bas qui ont jugé
bon de passer vacciner moi je ne
comprends pas cette décision n'est en
droit de le faire on est rendus dans
autre chose et moi je trouve c'est une
très très bonne nouvelle très bien
martin ce qu'avait dit aussi monsieur
legault c'est qu'il y avait quand même
certains départements la houle
la vaccination sera obligatoire
notamment dans les urgences il avait dit
je ne serai pas de passe droit dans les
urgences il y avait parlé aussi de
certaines régions où c'était quand même
assez réussi leur chez les travailleurs
de la santé mais effectivement les gens
qui ne sont pas être menée actuellement
c'est le noyau dur et visiblement ça
leur passe du pied par dessus la tête
suspendus ou pas alors ils n'ont pas
l'intention de se faire vacciner et on
n'a pas un les moyens au gouvernement de
laisser partir des gens sans solde sinon
le choix qu'on a à faire c'est on
pénalise ces gens là et les patients
dans certains endroits ne seront pas
soigné et il ya 10 à la situation on
doit ces gens voient la réalité en face
et est ce que ce n'est pas dans la
nature des choses dans une démocratie
libérale d'admettre qu'on peut pas que
les gens peuvent pas être vaccinés à 95
100 % n'est pas la chine si on est le
québec très bien rester là parce que
michel leblanc leur trouver dans nos les
les filons leur trouver et on va parler
du français et 2 du grand patron d'air
canada je vais avoir votre avis à vous
trois mais d'abord je vais parler michel
leblanc président et chef de la
direction la chambre de commerce honorem
bonjour monsieur leblanc
bon un petit mot quand même sur le
faible c'est passé un peu inaperçu mais
le gouvernement aujourd'hui a dit notre
recommandation du télétravail c'est
terminé
donc message aux entreprises vous pouvez
ramener les gens dans les tours à
bureaux je vais vous montrer des
chiffres c'est l'un le avant que les
gens reviennent au centre-ville vous le
savez mieux que moi il ya beaucoup de
gens qui m'aiment préfère rester à la
maison bon 47% sont encore en
télétravail et 71% sont un télétravail
soit resté en télétravail que ça vous
inquiète
la réalité c'est qu'effectivement de
tous découvert qu'on voit et mais les
modèles hybrides rester en télétravail
veut pas dire cinq jours par semaine on
l'a des données nous qui nous parle
aussi que beaucoup de gens se
ressemblent président lee et sans que
leurs maisons leurs appartements sont
mal conçus donc il y aura cette réalité
là est le message qu'a lancé le ministre
aujourd'hui était très important ça
devient une question d'organisation du
travail ce n'est plus une question de
sécurité sanitaire donc les entreprises
vont ramener les employés avec leurs
plans de retour j'attends impatiemment
que le gouvernement annonce comme
employeur ce qu'il va faire ça devrait
venir dans les prochains jours on espère
le centre-ville ont fait une analogie
avec un malade lorsqu'il se remet dans
quelle mesure en quel pourcentage il se
remet et qu'est ce qu'il reste à faire
écoutez il ya eu un coût morts il est
sorti du court mort mais il n'est pas
encore possible de sortir du lit c'est
clair que ça va prendre probablement
plusieurs mois on est ici les gens
revenir on veut combattre les motions de
peur par une émotion de plaisir et ça va
demander un effort de tout le monde
c'est clair et comme quoi je vous ai
cinq ans déjà le gouvernement d'israël
télétravail je le recommande plus qu'est
ce qu'il peut faire de plus eh bien il
les entreprises des employeurs ont déjà
plusieurs idées pour rendre les lieux de
travail beaucoup plus agréable mettre
l'emphase sur des lieux outre on
travaille en équipe par opposition à des
bureaux fixes beaucoup d'activités à
l'extérieur des heures de travail ce
qu'on voit beaucoup c'est les gens
disent moi j'ai envie de voir mes
collègues et donc les journées où ils
vont venir au bureau ça va des journées
de repos collectif savait déjà mais deux
sorties en groupe à la fin du travail
savez des journées de travail en
présence ou ont créé ensemble on
développe des propositions feraient
caméra faut que les employeurs soient
tyran dorlote la main d'oeuvre dorlote
légende oui et il a proposé des choses
agréables et ça va venir par les jeunes
c'est les jeunes qui sont les plus
claires présentement quelqu'un isolement
dans des appartements mal conçues pour
le télétravail la façon d'un bond des
discours tout en anglais à montréal à
profit son temps aussi tu rochon au
grand patron d'air canada va venir
parler chez vous demain midi il vous
signifie que tout son discours ce camp à
anglet est-ce que ça n'aurait pas été
votre rôle comme président achève la
direction de la chambre de commerce de
dire sur un saut peut pas faire ça à la
limite lisez l'on vous demande pas de de
réussite et du molière mais lisez une
phrase ou deux par respect non
écoutez on a on le dit ces choses là
quand on a invité monsieur rousseau dont
je rappelle à tout le monde air canada
steve pilier de notre économie si on a
retrouvé un statut d' de plaque
tournante à l'aéroport de dorval trudeau
c'est l'ajout de ces liaisons directes
air canada achète des airbus 220 des
cseries c'est fondamental de les
travailleurs chez nous bref et c'est un
nouveau président qui rentrent en poste
pendant la pandémie qui est peu connu
donc on l'invité et je leur ai
inviterait demain matin il ya quelques
jours on a appris que son discours à
l'aise en anglais qu'il se sentait très
mal à l'aise de parler français
auront leur signifier que ça devrait
contenir du français c'est leur décision
et je pense que présentement air canada
y voit bien la réalité au québec ça
passe mal il sera à notre tribune de
mendy on verra presque ce contenu quels
seront ceux comptant aussi mais c'est
clair que moi je le répète le milieu des
affaires à un consensus très puissant la
langue commune et la langue de travail
au québec c'est le français n'y a pas
d'ambiguïté là dessus donc vous avez
demandé où j'allais vous ayez eu des
va-et-vient avec air canada il vous leur
avez dit ça serait bien qu'ils ajoutent
du français c'est ce que vous me dites
j'ai dit que ce serait bien mais j'ai
dit que ça passerait difficilement si
c'était pas le cas
vous restiez qui peut pas même lire
parce que certains qui habitent à
longueuil voit enfin sur la rive sud ils
peuvent même pas lire une phrase c'est
ce grain président peut pas lire une
phrase en français écoutez moi je le
reçois de mes midi je vais découvrir
comme vous le contenu et le contenant
les messages ont été passées ce qu'on
nous a répondu cheikh canada c'est merci
beaucoup de nous en informer je pense
qu'ils n'avaient pas besoin de nous et
on les laisse prendre leur décision moi
je le répète encore une fois je vais
toujours évité à ma tribune à la chambre
de commerce tous les gens qui ont un
impact super important sur notre
économie sur notre débat faire et ces
gens là auront à s'expliquer évidemment
mais air canada revoit de détenir des
leviers très important pour montréal
dans la prochaine année vous êtes y
était pas question de ne pas inviter
monsieur rousseau en fait le désinvité
si je peux le dire parce qu'il n'allait
pas parlant français compte tenu de
l'importance de son entreprise pour
montréal exactement et il subit ou
subira à la fois les loges s'ils
proposent des choses comme il faut et de
la bonne façon où les conséquences ça
lui appartient mais nous comme une
tribune pour que les gens comprennent
qu'elles sont les destinées des grands
joueurs des grandes entreprises la
région celle leblanc va suivre ça
peut-être que finalement
il rend peu de français on verra demain
on va suivre ça avec vous merci michel
leblanc président et chef de direction
de chambre de commerce de montréal merci
beaucoup alors je repose la question
mais pénalise
martin christian allex
monsieur leblanc lui même qui a écrit le
discours il dit qui lui a demandé on dit
non il dit lors je peux pas ne pas
éviter air canada allait qu'est ce que
tu en penses
ce qu'ils pouvaient ne pas inviter air
canada que je pense que c'est une
décision qui le pouvaient prendre
lorsqu'il a su que cisco serait
entièrement en anglais we le décide de
ne pas le faire étant donné le poids que
représente le canada dans l'économie
québécoise qui substantielle sur la
décision de la chambre de commerce moi
je pense qu'ils avaient le choix au delà
de ça je pense qu'un problème historique
d'air canada avec la langue française
dont le vieux au nombre de plaintes qui
ont été déposées auprès du commissaire
aux langues officielles fédéral au fil
des pas les cinq six dernières années il
a au fil des trente dernières années sur
la difficulté d'être servis en français
chez air canada à la limite c'est bien
des gens qui comprennent qu'une liaison
edmonton vancouver où il ya plus de
francophones souhaitent pas simple de
recruter des agents de bord qui parlent
français à l'autre bout du pays mais qu
un président dont le siège social est à
montréal à sa charge historique la
société d'état avec le français
l'ancienne société d'état avec le
français qui vit ici depuis plusieurs
années ne sont pas capables de faire un
quart à un tiers de son discours en
français comme point d'y loger des gens
des ministres tenir ou là capable de
faire du beau en france est très proche
et cheech un risque politique mais ils
se disent d'essayer au moins il ne
faisait pas semblant qu'il il est
capable au moins prononcé quelques mots
honnêtement cette histoire là me semble
totalement inacceptable et même jusqu'au
conseil d'administration d'air canada de
juger bon de nommer ce pdg le 100 mètres
le critère du français comme étant
prépondérant moi je trouve ça très très
étonne il habite depuis sept ans québec
je le répète c'est pas un américain
compte aller chercher ça aurait pu être
le cas c'est simple wallace et si un
marché international
et plus de gens peuvent être qualifiés
christia qu'est ce que vous en pensez
que l'arrogance en fait le président
d'air canada une destination qui est qui
bilingue selon la loi vient de parler à
montréal juste en anglais monsieur
leblanc dit que ça passerait mal sa
passe pas du tout et moi il ya monsieur
roger assez l'attention au panel que
c'est lui que le plus de pouvoir dans ce
dossier là c'est pas juste ça sinon j'en
ai marre est puis amélie et julie de
défendre le français ceto francophones
qu'il soit en position d'autorité je
trouve que c'est un corps ou une
escouade ce serait bon scandale ce
serait bon et je trouve qu'il aurait pas
dû lui interdire aux s'excusant réel des
portes par les ports français ne le
prenez pas mal mais nous on ne peut pas
vous à éviter si vous parlais pas
français et lors de la conférence de
même aux yeux des participants lors
qu'ils font des problèmes là c'est pas
moi qui va les plaindre que ça vaut
vraiment la peine qui est un esclave on
n'est pas prêt à accepter ça et je
trouvais que monsieur leblanc et
représentent une partie des élites
québécois je suis pas tout le monde
parce les francophones on dirait qu'ils
ont des mails par remonter pour le
français le français mans pratiques qui
se couchent sont toujours en train de se
coucher c'est totalement inacceptable
martin je suis allé sur le site des
comptables agréés du canada pour voir
cette biographie et c'est un site
bilingue puis en français si tu as
marqué la biographie n'est disponible
qu'en anglais alors il est très assumé
c'est un peu
c'est désolant certainement quand on
voit justement le projet de loi pour
protéger la langue c'est sûr que le
gouvernement doit compter sur ses
leaders et monsieur rousseau s'est pas
sentie mesure où ce monsieur rousseau
mais il est pas là et il vit au québec
et c'est certain qu'un vrai pas un
signal fort il ya aux citoyens il ya
quelque chose qui fait 1972 dans tout
cela ça sonne 1972 merci à vous trois
très gentil d'avoir attendu puisque
monsieur leblanc dont
sa merci beaucoup à vous trois bars
soirées au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit